ich möchte einen kleinen denkanstoß
geben der lautet wir sind nicht allein
auf dieser welt wir sind es nicht in
deutschland wir sind auch nicht im
bereich der europäischen union wenn wir
dinge in unserem sinne ändern wollen wir
stimmen den zielen durchaus überein
brauchen wir partner und wir haben
partner
wir haben und mit denen arbeite ich mit
meiner delegation jeden tag zusammen wir
haben partner in der italienischen liga
im raster national beim vlaams belang in
der dänischen volkspartei und den vielen
anderen bei den finden ich könnte weiter
aufzählen
und da tut sich gerade etwas durch den
austritt der ungarischen fidesz partei
aus der svp ist der bewegung
reingekommen und es finden derzeit viele
gespräche statt manches davon geht auch
durch die presse aber nicht alles wenn
wir hier etwas verändern wollen dann
müssen wir mit diesen partnern
zusammenarbeiten wenn wir jetzt hier
wenn sie zeuge hingehen und sagen wir
wollen aber raus aus dem laden dann sage
ich die werden mit uns nicht mehr
zusammenarbeiten
dazwischen die vorbereitung eines
zusammenschlusses statt an dem ihr
teilhaben sollten denn nur dann ist
können wir das politische gewicht
einbringen
wir müssen immer überlegen ob es uns
aktuell nutzt und das wäre mit der decke
forderung nicht der fall
es gibt einen entscheidenden unterschied
zwischen dem praxis und dem text beim
wechsel war von vorneherein klar dass
die eu dann aach noch existieren würde
wenngleich amputiert um ein wichtiges
glied ein text würde bedeuten dass die
eu nicht mehr existiert und das würde
bei der wählerschaft
das würde das würde bei der wählerschaft
eine tiefe verunsicherung erzeugen die
uns stimmen kostet und das können wir
uns zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt da nicht
erlauben wenn wir uns als souveräner
staat begreifen dann kann unser
bundestagswahlprogramm was wir hier
aufstellen nicht davon abhängig sein was
wir für mögliche zusammenarbeit mit der
viele später in ungarn oder sonstigen in
der fraktion unter umständen zusammen
kriegen was ich durchaus befürworte aber
wir reden hier jetzt über unser
wahlprogramm für die bundestagswahl
und da spielen um die fraktions
zusammensetzung aus dem eu parlament
keinerlei rolle bei allem respekt das
muss gesagt werden
danke herr professor neuen es gibt
fragen politische fragen darf man
taktieren es gibt aber auch politische
fragen da darf man nicht taktieren weil
es um die politische identität geht hier
ist es eine solche hier wird nicht mehr
taktiert wir brauchen den aus bild und
die brauchen wir als signal in unserem
bundestags froh am dankeschön nächste
wortmeldung roten saal mikrofon bitte
eine minute redezeit liebe parteifreunde
und sozialen klar die politik der
europäischen union ist für unser land
fatal
und es gibt denke ich mir auch keine
diskussion dass es so nicht weitergehen
kann
wir müssen uns aber endlich mal zu einem
inhaltlichen in der inhaltlichen
positionierung bekennen weil diese
positionierung einfach richtig ist und
nicht weil sie uns im moment ein paar
wählerstimmen kosten könnte
wir müssen geradlinige politik machen
glaubwürdige politik machen wir müssen
in fünf jahren
zurückschauen können und sagen können ja
das war richtig dass wir uns damals als
erste bekannt haben zu einem austritt
aus der eu
ich kann verstehen nach allem was die eu
mit uns anstellt dass der wunsch nach
dem wechselt hier auch groß und stark
ist
und ich kann diesen wunsch auch
nachvollziehen
es gibt aber ein problem das wir immer
nach zwei verlorenen weltkriegen sehen
müssen
wir müssen eine alternative zugleich auf
machen wir müssen deutlich sagen dass
wenn deutschland aus der eu austritt es
eine andere gemeinsamkeit mit unseren
europäischen nachbarn haben will
wir können sozusagen nicht nur das eine
sagen und das andere nicht denn eins
müssen wir deutlich sehen
das wird auch wenn wir ganz andere
gründe haben
von europäern unter umständen falsch
verstanden und es geht unter umständen
wieder die sorge um vor den deutschen
sonderweg ja freunde ich bin im
endergebnis für den austritt aus der eu
aber nur wenn wir alternativ klar machen
dass wir mit europäischen staaten
zusammenarbeiten auch in einer
organisation die stimmung hier im saal
und deshalb bauland es kann nicht sein
dass wir in georgia reden von 19 7
schützt sich paraphrasieren die eu ist
nicht europa wir sind nicht gegen europa
aber wir sind gegen eu ropa und es ist
allerhöchste zeit dass dieser antrag
endlich eine mehrheit findet und haben
wollten selbst hat 2009/10 schon gesagt
dass ich mit einem gewissen ablauf
endlich da nach der auszeit erfolgen
muss wir sind zwei billionen weisheit
wir haben zwei organ klagen laufen gegen
die eu es ist auch wirtschaftlich nicht
mehr verantwortbar und da müssen
taktische spielereien von fraktions
debatten im eu parlament will ich gar
nicht reden zurückstehen und ich werde
auch diesen antrag zu stimmen aus der eu
auszutreten weil die eu sterben muss
wenn deutschland leben will
zu den kritischen worten ich sag das war
ganz deutlich es geht hier nicht um
taktik spielchen
es geht hier auch nicht daran sich zu
erfreuen mit der flash oder der leger
oder wem auch immer
bündnisse zu schmieden es geht darum
politik zu gestalten
politik ist die kunst des möglichen
und wir werden wenn wir jetzt hier
unseren austritt willen erklären nichts
erreichen nicht im wahlkampf nicht in
berlin nicht in brüssel nicht wir
erreichen gar nichts außer dass eine
willensbekundung gemacht haben ich war
bis vor einer viertelstunde ein
glühender vertreter eines sofortigen
austritt aus der eu und zwar aus tritt
mit arschtritt möglichst heftig aber die
worte von herrn professor mountain haben
mich eines besseren belehrt wir ja ist
so wir würden uns eines wichtigen
taktischen mittel berauben und ich
glaube auch in der wählerschaft thema
ein sofortiger bedingungsloser austritt
nicht gut an wenn wir nicht vorher alle
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft hätten
die eu ist leider nicht reformierbar wir
haben das festgestellt und die zweite
klarstellung geht was herr gauland
richtigerweise gesagt hat sie es braucht
natürlich eine alternative aber diese
alternative haben wir der bp 33 sagt zum
ende ganz klar dass wir beim austritt
die gründung einer neuen europäischen
wirtschafts-und interessengemeinschaft
anstreben
lieber herr huber sie haben richtig
gesagt im wp 33 steht drin dass wir dann
eine neue europäische wirtschafts- und
interessengemeinschaft gründen sollen da
muss ich mal die frage stellen was ist
das denn also wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
das gibt wieder sehr stark in richtung
wirtschaftsunion und wirtschaftsunion
heißt um zwei wieder binnenmarkt ich bin
der meinung unser wahlprogramm darf auch
ecken und kanten haben unter eben noch
als oppositionsführer programm erkennbar
sein
herr professor dr ich muss mich dann
jetzt trainer an dass wir uns selbst
überflüssig machen wollen
ich weiß nicht mehr wann sie es gesagt
zu haben ist eine weile her aber auf gar
keinen fall letzte eindruck entstehen
dass wir nicht mehr teil der lösung
sondern teil des problems geworden sind
klare kante ja raus aus der eu nicht
raus europa aus europa dafür stehen wir
wir stehen hinter europa wir stehen zu
europa wir sind in europa beheimatet das
war richtig aber wir müssen raus aus der
eu und das müssen wir endlich mal klar
und deutlich vor aussprechen und dazu
auch stehen alles andere bringt uns
nichts und das ungeheure muss endlich
mal aufhören
ich finde die abstimmung zu beenden und
das ergebnis einzublenden
der antrag ist angenommen meine damen
und herren